vous y croyez à l'inspiration divine
croyez vraiment que les idées de
dissertation vont tomber du ciel dans un
faisceau de lumière
moi pas trop après avoir écrit des
centaines de dissertation je peux vous
assuré ça ne marche pas comment est ce
que j'ai trouvé l'idée de cette vidéo et
bien c'est vous qui me l'avait donné des
élèves m'ont posé la question dans les
commentaires
et par email et je vais leur répondre
dans cette vidéo mais avant de rentrer
dans la réponse proprement dit on doit
se demander de quelle idée par le ton
c'est quoi les idées en dissertation bon
en fait simple en dissertation les idées
ce sont les éléments de réponse au
problème intellectuel c'est à dire les
éléments de réponse à la problématique
dans votre plan détaillé les idées ce
sont les grandes parties et sous parties
s'il y en a et les arguments donc la
question à laquelle je vais répondre
c'est plus précisément comment trouver
les idées des partis et des arguments
d'une dissertation là c'est plus facile
de répondre déjà et si vous voulez
améliorer votre capacité à trouver des
idées en dissertation vous avez besoin
d'une méthodologie solide
inscrivez vous donc à mon cours gratuits
de méthodologie soit en cliquant sur le
lien qui apparaît maintenant en haut à
droite de la vidéo soit en cliquant sur
celui qui est dans la description de
cette vidéo vous m'en direz des
nouvelles
et vous verrez qu'une fois que vous
aurez lu mon cours tout sera plus clair
dans votre esprit et trouver des idées
pour votre dissertation sera plus facile
après il existe trois solutions précises
pour trouver des idées en dissertation
je vais vous les données de la plus
facile à la plus difficile
regardez bien attentivement cette vidéo
et l'inspiration ne sera plus un
problème pour vous en dissertation
la solution la plus facile pour trouver
des idées en dissertation c'est de
puiser dans votre réservoir personnel et
d'idées tout près imaginez pendant
l'année scolaire vous avez traité un
sujet sur la démocratie et aux concours
vous avez de la chance c'est un sujet de
dissertation sur la démocratie qui tombe
bon et bien qu'est ce que vous faites
vous n'allez pas faire comme si vous
étiez amnésique
non bien au contraire vous avez intérêt
à vous remémorer le plan détaillé que
vous avez élaboré pendant l'année
scolaire parce que vous allez
probablement pouvoir reprendre la
plupart des idées de ce plan détaillé
c'est à dire les partis les arguments
alors vous allez me dire mais c'est un
coup de chance
bien sûr pour l'élève qui n'a traité que
deux trois sujets pendant l'année c'est
un vrai coup de chance mais pour l'élève
qui a fait 50 plans détaillés sur 50
sujet de dissertation différents pendant
l'année vous pensez vraiment que c'est
un coup de chance
si au concours sept élèves s'ils tombent
sur un sujet qui ressemble à un sujet
qu'il a déjà traité
et bien non au contraire c'est assez
probable pourquoi parce qu'il est très
bien préparée si vous voulez trouver
très facilement des idées en
dissertation
la solution c'est donc de traiter un
maximum de sujets et d'élaborer un
maximum de plan détaillé pour vous
préparer à l'épreuve de dissertation
comme ça vous aurez un très large
répertoire personnel d'idées toutes
prêtes pour la dissertation et vous
n'aurez plus qu'à puiser dedans bien sûr
vous devez le faire intelligemment
l'idée que vous réutiliser doit être
pertinente c'est à dire qu'il doit
répondre précisément à la problématique
de la dissertation mais que faire si
vous ne trouver aucune idée pertinente
en repensant aux sujets que vous avez
déjà traités
la deuxième solution pour trouver des
idées en dissertation c'est de puiser
dans vos connaissances et de transformer
un élément de connaissances en une idée
de dissertation imaginer des sujets qui
tombe porte sur la démocratie et vous
avez justement eu un cours sur la
démocratie ou bien vous avez justement
ficher un chapitre de manuels sur la
démocratie pourrait bien vous allez vous
en servir mais le problème c'est que
votre courroux votre fischer la
démocratie ce n'est pas le même format
qu'une dissertation c'est rare que ce
soit le même forme
du coup il y à un effort de
transformation de l'information à
fournir
vous devez transformer un élément de
connaissances issues de votre courroux
de votre fiche en une idée de
dissertation c'est pour ça que cette
deuxième solution est plus difficile et
puis ça dépend de la nature de l'élément
de connaissances donc vous vous souvenez
s'il ressemble à une idée de
dissertation alors la transformation
sera facile
par exemple si dans votre cour il y à
une partie sur les différentes formes de
démocratie et bien vous pourrez utiliser
l'idée il existe diverses formes de
démocratie
en revanche s'il éléments de
connaissance dont vous vous souvenez ne
ressemble pas à une idée de dissertation
alors là la transformation sera plus
compliqué par exemple si votre co
analyse les différentes formes de
démocratie une par une
alors c'est à vous d'en déduire
l'existence de l'idée pertinente
il existe diverses formes de démocratie
donc en pratique plus l'élément de
connaissances ressemble à une idée
dissertation plus la transformation sera
facile par exemple si vous vous souvenez
que rousseau a dit dans du contrat
social que la démocratie diack est
difficile à mettre en place
eh bien vous pourrez vous approprier
cette idée vous pourrez par exemple
écrire que la démocratie directe peut
sembler utopique
dans cet exemple c'est facile mais ça ne
sera pas toujours le cas vous devez
estimé l'effort de transformation
nécessaire en fonction de la nature de
l'élément de connaissances dont vous
vous souvenez et du degré de précision
de sept éléments de connaissance s'il
est prêt si vous pourrez peut-être en
tirer une idée précise c'est à dire un
argument mais s'il éléments de
connaissance n'est pas apprécié alors
vous pourrez peut-être en tirer une idée
générale c'est-à-dire l'idée d'une
grande partie de la dissertation et vous
pouvez encore trouvé une idée générale à
partir d'un alignement de connaissances
précis et inversement
mais là la transformation être encore
plus compliqué je vais donc pas arrêté
là pour cette deuxième solution même si
moi est un sujet qui me passionne la
manipulation des idées retenez que si
vous ne trouvez pas une idée certes à
sion toute prête
vous pouvez transformer un élément de
connaissances en une idée de
dissertation mais c'est parfois
compliqué donc moi je vous conseille de
traiter un maximum de sujets de faire un
maximum de plan détaillé pour vous
faciliter la vie
le jour j maintenant que faire si vous
ne trouvez pas assez d'idées voir aucune
idée avec les deux premières solutions
la troisième solution pour trouver des
idées en dissertation c'est de prier non
je plaisante hein même si on n'est pas
loin
la troisième solution pour trouver des
idées en dissertation et bien c'est
d'imaginer qu'on vous pose la question
de la problématique et que vous devez
répondre dans les deux premières
solutions vous fouillez directement dans
des stocks de réponse entre guillemets
pour voir s'il n'y en a pas une qui peut
convenir mais dans la troisième solution
vous élaborez les mende réponse vous
même ah oui c'est bien plus difficile
là je ne peux pas vous donner d'exemple
parce que je ne suis pas sûr de
comprendre comment l'esprit fonctionne
pour trouver une idée ce que je peux
vous dire c'est que vous avez intérêt à
essayer de simuler une conversation
imaginez vous qu'un ami vous pose la
question de la problématique et essayait
vraiment de lui répondre
vous allez voir que vous allez trouver
quelques idées elles ne seront pas aussi
bonne que celle que vous auriez trouvé
avec les deux premières solutions mais
c'est toujours mieux que rien en fait
cette troisième solution ça consiste à
faire de manière méthodique ce que font
la grande majorité des élèves qui ne
sont pas du tout préparés à l'épreuve de
dissertation pour trouver les idées ils
laissent leur esprit divaguer pour
suivre des pistes au hasard et se perdre
mais vous vous ne ferez pas ça vous
dirigerez votre esprit parce que vous
imaginerez que vous essayez de répondre
précisément à un ami qui vous a posé une
question après ça sera quand même bien
plus facile de trouver des idées
si vous avez traité des sujets qui
ressemble à celui de l'épreuve
donc encore une fois pour mettre toutes
les chances de votre côté faites un
maximum de plans détaillés
en synthèse les trois solutions pour
trouver des idées en dissertation ce
sont eux reprend des idées que vous avez
déjà utilisé dans des plans détaillés
vous avez élaboré au cours de votre
préparation deuxième solution de
transformer des éléments de connaissance
d'eux qu'ils viennent de les transformer
en idées de dissertation et enfin
troisième solution d'imaginer une
conversation avec un ami pour trouver
vous même les éléments de réponse mais
si vous voulez réussir vos dissertation
vous ne ferez pas ça vous vous
entraînerez en traitant le maximum de
sujets enfin vous le ferez après vous
être inscrit à mon cours gratuits de
méthodologie vous pouvez vous y inscrire
soit en cliquant sur le lien qui
apparaît maintenant en haut à droite de
la vidéo soit en cliquant sur celui qui
est dans la description de cette vidéo
puis vous pouvez aussi me donner de
nouvelles idées et de vidéos dans les
commentaires parce que pour l'instant
les dieux ne m'ont rien donné
vous m'avez demandé cette vidéo donc
j'espère vraiment qu'elle vous sera
utile je suis rom auch toujours avec mon
fidèle aristote qui dort toujours et
vous étiez sur mille idées de culture
générale rappelez vous n'avez pas besoin
de vous prendre la tête pour trouver des
idées en dissertation
[Musique]